hello and welcome to game on episode 4 I
am Todd Kerpelman I'm a developer
advocate here on play games hello my
name is Hakeem Matsuda underdo developer
advocate for gaming technologies and
today we're gonna be talking about
OpenGL ES 3.0 before we get into that
let's jump into some news and updates
not a whole lot this this time in terms
of news and updates except that we've
got more info on cloud save this this
guy Tom Fitzgerald who happens to be a
Googler email me earlier today and said
hey I saw your I saw your show so we
have at least one viewer thanks Tom
about cloud save and I went and added it
into my own html5 game and he put up a
YouTube video where he sort of talks
about the process shows you is code it's
pretty quick it's all of about you know
three and a half minutes but if we're
all interested in doing more with cloud
safe particularly in a web-based game I
encourage you to check it out and I
suppose this is something that's
important to point out is cloud save
it's not just for mobile games it's also
very useful in a browser-based game
local storage is is very cool for html5
but it does have the disadvantage that
you basically can't keep your storage
between browsers or obviously across
different computers that's why it's
called local storage and so if you have
to deal with the player that is either
playing on different browsers or on
different computers or on a tablet and a
computer again look into cloud save and
you can look into what this guy tom has
done in his youtube video so with that
let's get into the main subject of
today's talk and that is OpenGL ES 3
ocurro your expert so I'll let you take
it away ok
so for today I'd like to introduce you
new API in Android 4.3 OpenGL ES 3
OpenGL ES 3 is a superset of existing
OpenGL ES 2 so that you can use your
existing game called
OpenGL es2 without any changes you can
adopt some of the advanced feature set
of OpenGL ES 3 and get the benefit of
them quite easy in es3 it supports
multiple new features which can be
categorized into three areas performance
quality and flexibility poor performance
es which support several advanced
features such as such as the transform
feedback geometry instancing occlusion
query and multiple rendering target the
transform feedback it's quite a useful
feature to the mass in GPU side rather
than CPU side you can update your
buttocks perfect entries directory based
on the Mustang at the GPU without
involving any CPU this point good for
you since a particle engine was such as
skinning x GPU with multiple rendering
path also geometry instancing
is features that can then the multiple
instances of geometry with just one API
call with the different parameters the
frigid beautiful balls CP on the GPU
performance because you don't have to
call API multiple times and also GPU has
hardware support to handle them
efficiently for games that renders same
object
multiple times you should use that video
other features such as a multi which can
render to multiple render buffer at the
same time and occlusion query which can
check GPU if geometry is visible or not
they are also great to leaders both
cheaply on the GPU load dramatically
let's talk about quality side in es3 it
support ET g2 as a standard texture
compression format ET ce to supports the
alpha channel and produced better
quality for bit per channel which quite
small as a regular texture format it
replaces ET c1 and various as a GPU
dependent formats like txt so that you
can finally use one single texture
compression format in your games with
GES three also adds an optional feature
you can have a nice pc adaptive
scaleable texture compression format
texture format that is much more
advanced are the better quality texture
format SPC is supported in some GPU such
as Mali GPU
yes three also supports floating points
textures so that you can do real high
dummy high dynamic range rendering in
your games not a fake a TTL for
flexibility side it supports features
like non power to textures so that you
can have arbitral dementia over the
textures not not limited to the power to
size and it supports more than the
target format and texture format as well
also you can attach dips buffets the
texture in es3 shader languages also
updated to GLSL ES 3.0 which support
integer and other new language features
so in general ES 3 supports comparable
feature set of desktop ajob opengl 3.1
or DirectX 10 except support of geometry
shader which can produce more triangles
after a vertex shader stage so that with
GL es 3 you can put your games quite
easily to mobile platform in performance
wise mobile GPUs with GL es 3 support
has comparable performance range of low
or middle range desktop GPU which is
quite surprising for me because mobile
GPU works on 1/10 of low energy usage
currently SDK 18 and in the DK out nine
post supports GL es 3 and all over the
Nexus 4 710 supports the areas ES 3
please try new feature set over 2 years
3m enjoy him oh cool that all sounds
very exciting
yeah that likes that likes a good
graphics in my games I want to ask about
when you talk about some of the some of
the performance improvement so geometry
instancing I think I understand like if
I had I don't know 50 cars in my game at
all you know we're essentially the same
I would essentially only define one car
model yes and kind of save on a whole
lot of geometry passing by saying just
reuse this car model of arises in 3
years - you had to call the API 15 times
in this this example but with GL es 3
you can then the 15 cars at one single
API call that's cool yeah in Android
basically API call it's not quite cheap
so that it's a great performance wing
gotcha
now could I could I have different
textures or different colors on top of
these cars and still the advantage yes
exactly so you can have different
parameters like transform texture UVs
and any other parameter can be different
by mo do business gosh
so again I I feel like I there at one
point there was a lot of games that
featured like crowd scenes or all of a
sudden they were drawing a lot of people
they're basically taking advantage of
this technique and kind of putting
different skins on the same model so
that you get the impression of a lot of
people right let's do you ok well that's
pretty clever
um I still don't quite understand what
transform feedbacks are is that is that
something you can explain further is
that really just like yes so in general
in ES 2 is that transform or GPU mercy
it's just a one-way so
CPU issues render command and the GPU to
some work yeah and then died
that was it but in OpenGL ES 3 you can
free the box
output mass of the GPU into the buffer
again so that you can update geometry
skin while you camp this particle
position inside the GPU and right back
to the buffer so that in each frame you
can do some us completely it's a GPU
side okay that's
let's start to make more sense to me
yeah alright so like if would that work
if I had to say perform the same kind of
you know transform and scale to multiple
objects could I take advantage of yeah
that feature there exactly okay
and Marty multiple render targets is
that like the feature where I can kind
of like sometimes in the background you
might see a TV that's showing kind of
what's going on in my game well it's
mainly for the multi-purpose you know
inside years to to do the multiple paths
rendering in fact you had to Linda
normal at this bus and the color
dispersed and that's the final years of
us
you need to fetch these then the result
at the final registering pass but in the
MRT you can output to different values
into a different target okay so that you
don't have to draw same thing twice but
just was and at the final gathering pass
deferred rendering path you can get to
result at the same time
gotcha so like what kind of what
techniques would you see using making
use of MRT well we said deferred
rendering deferred rendering the
technicals been the similar parameter
object into several profiles and I guess
it's a finer pass you can get a great
benefit of reality in terms of the
performance okay yes well let's see I
think we have let's move on to a demo
we've got a cool demo that was put
together by the good folks at silicon
studio I guess this is I don't know if
it has a name except maybe rings and
jewels that we show it off at the Nexus
7 launch event just last month
that makes use of some fairly cool
that's PS 3.0 techniques let's uh let's
bring this up this is recorded on a new
Nexus 7 device that I think Dan said I
couldn't keep after this session is done
right he's laughing which i think means
yes so alright we've got these these
very cool shiny rings and I can click
this Add button and add in a few jewels
and they fall down and knock over the
Rings and it looks very cool yeah
physical simulation I've seen it's a CP
aside it's really close Phoenix
yeah nice it's nice physics so what are
we seeing here that's being done by GL
es 3 well in GL es 3 mod Z using
afro-latino texture so that everything
is and that is a high dynamic range okay
I've noticed there there is a switch
here I can switch es 3 on and off and
when I notice when I turn it off there's
a few things that happen one you don't
kind of get the nice shine on the Rings
like you do before you kind of get a
little bit of lens flare off the ring
reflections and that goes away I've also
noticed the the table texture looks much
blurrier what's happening like right so
in the fake a TDR mode which is it's
OpenGL es2
thing harder to be in range of 0 to 255
which is one bite range but in the
OpenGL ES 3 it can have the broad
dynamic range so that it can show more
details on everything gotcha
so that's why when I turn on yet yeah GL
ES 3.0 we need a cooler of codename for
that and that that's why the table
suddenly looks so much more detailed is
you know we're able to suddenly spend
more kind of basically more data per
pixel on riot criticize me okay and in
some I know something also seems to be
happening with the gems I'm not quite
sure is it somehow doing different type
of refraction or um you know why switch
on and off ES 3.0 I notice that there's
something that I can't quite articulate
with the gems where they look much
better with it on my Illinois yes
basically it's also thanks to the high
dynamic range so that the AG of situates
can be sharper and deflection can be
clearer in Southie area 3 gotcha
alright oh cool so alright I could I
could play with this for a long time but
I won't because we have other stuff to
you in our show but uh excellent so
let's see yeah other QA so in terms of
what devices support OpenGL ES 3 you
would mention the the Nexus 4 the Nexus
the new Nexus M isn't an excessively yes
and the Nexus 10 right other other other
devices out there how would I know if
the device oh well in general also today
GPU from Qualcomm like Adreno 320 and
the 330 she the supports a Giri is 3
also GPU from mali t600
should support the GL es 3
like well maybe that brings us to our
third question so if I'm a developer and
you know maybe I want to add in some of
this OpenGL ES 3 you know techniques to
my game but at the same time you
actually want to support a large range
of devices what what do you do with your
code to make sure that you can still
mm-hmm yeah basically to make sure that
that I can kind of have have an engine
that that looks really nice on the on
the machines that support it but doesn't
you know crash or something yeah that's
great question so uh yeah a little bit
today mostly most almost all the Android
device like 99% of device supports
OpenGL ES 2 but just a fraction percent
support GL es 3 so exactly that number
will probably grow yeah in future not be
3 yes that's my hope but as of today you
need to have 2 corpus whines for GL es 3
and another one for GL ES 2 also you can
check the existence of some OpenGL GPU
extension so that you can even with the
GL ES 2 you can still use utilize some
of the advanced to feature set available
for cs3 so I might for instance out of
some hardware manufacturer might have a
chipset that officially supports GS 2
but might support one or two features
from the OpenGL ES 3 right and so that's
something that a developer could check
on a feature by feature basis yeah
because I have 3 so it sounds like
complicated but it's kind of a kind like
PC like gaming model so in the PC you
need to check all of the feature
existing to utilize its most out of GPIO
service hardware so that you need to the
same single Android device so yeah it's
really not much different than what a
lot of PC developers are already doing
today right and maybe that brings us to
our second question which is I might
decide as a game developer this sounds
like a lot of work maybe I'll find an
engine
this for me are there other engines out
there that support this already yes so
many game engines like unity and unreal
engine already supports a GL es 3 okay
so that they are for me i GL es 3 is
really easy to use but for somebody in
my tunnel souls that you can still use a
game engine to support GE is three other
ones to feed yourself okay
and I guess actually that that might
bring up good segue we do have one other
demo which is is the Unity engine and I
suppose maybe some of this really isn't
so much showing off OpenGL ES 3 features
so much is kind of showing how how nice
things look on the Nexus 7 but it sounds
like they are probably doing a fair
amount of OpenGL ES 3 performances yeah
equals F 3 so say yeah well they don't
run this this is called the chase and I
noticed there they're showing a fair
number of features going on here in
terms of atmospheric scattering you know
4 kilometer of draw distance
I think they talked about sub yes yes so
that the CI using really high polygon
model means I entire scene it's a it's
rendering more than 200 250,000 polygons
in that scene which is you clean
critical high number in terms of some
mobile gaming also I mean this looks
like this yeah this looks like a console
game yeah exactly and also they are
using some other ones to feature set of
side OpenGL ES 3 for performance
improvement mainly so that with years
two devices that demo still works but
with ES 3 it can utilize features atoms
like occlusion culling to checks if
science visible in the same and also
it's using geometry instancing
than the
so that it can benefit those performance
of surgery is three features it all
right that's very cool you know my
biggest complaint with this demo is I
can't figure out who the good guy who
the bad guy is they both sort of look
you know kind of sinister they're both
you know kind of shooting in in amongst
all the civilian traffic which really
isn't all that safe maybe neither one is
actually the good guy maybe maybe but I
suppose that's a little off-topic
so uh awesome this look this looks great
I can't wait to try out more games on
this device that Dan is letting me take
home so thanks again Dan and we'll bring
up our final slide which is if you want
more information about OpenGL ES 3 this
is basically our our OpenGL page on
Annelle for Android com
yes also we are releasing some more some
protocol to fall in the decay on the G
by sneaking for OpenGL ES 3 that would
be fantastic
yes awesome all right well thank you
very much for for joining us thank you
thank you out there for joining us and
we will see you in a couple of weeks
with our next game on session if we
don't get cancelled all right